-Thank you.
So great to see you again,
because we got to start
off the week together.
-We did, yeah.
-You went to the Met Gala.
And here's a photo of you here.
Look at this.
Stunner.
Looking gorgeous in...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-...gorgeous in Thom Browne.
We sat at the same table.
-Yeah.
-We were taping.
-I had a great time with you.
-We did, right?
We had fun.
-Yeah, I feel like I had
the Met Gala with Jimmy Fallon.
It was the best experience
I could have had.
You were cracking me up
the whole time.
-I want to talk to you
about "Dear Evan Hansen,"
but I also want to talk to you
about your musical abilities.
You can -- You can sing.
-Wow. Thanks.
-I mean, would you -- would you
ever put out music as you?
-Totally, yeah.
I'm en route to that,
into releasing music.
-Do you record anything?
-Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I have
a single droppin' soon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait. What?
Really?
That's fantastic.
And how does it --
Do you get nervous when you --
when you do these things,
and you're like --
'Cause, like, I watched
this movie, and I'm like,
"Oh, if I even did
one scene of that --"
I can do it joking around,
but really singing in front
of all these people
and Ben Platt, as well,
I go, "Oof."
-Oh, yeah, I was so nervous.
Yeah, 'cause I come from film,
you know, so I wasn't --
Like, I'm not well-versed
in the world of musical theater.
In my scene in particular,
I remember talking
to Kaitlyn Dever
before we shot the film
and being like,
"I'm really nervous
to sing in front of people."
And she was like, "Don't worry.
It's gonna be chill.
Most of the scenes take place
in bedrooms and hallways,
and it's very intimate."
And I remember thinking,
"Okay, cool."
And then, Stephen Chbosky,
our director,
calls me and is like,
"So, your scene's
gonna take place
during an all-school assembly."
[ Laughter ]
-The most people in any scene
in the whole movie.
-Yes, an all-school assembly.
150 people are watching you.
-150 people there.
Yeah.
So, you know, we get to the day,
and I perform the scene,
and it goes well and everything.
And then, at the end of the day,
the sound guys are like,
"We really need to get a clean
vocal tracking of the song,
so what we're gonna have
everyone do
is get in a large circle,
and we're gonna put you
in the middle of the circle,
and then you're gonna perform
the entire song a cappella."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a nightmare.
-There was, like,
this demon ring of human beings,
like 150 people
just in dead silence,
like, staring at me
while I performed the song.
But they were all really lovely
and also, like, fans
of "Dear Evan Hansen,"
so it went all right.
-But they added two new songs
to the soundtrack
for this film adaptation,
and you're one of the songs.
-Yeah.
-Congrats on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's fantastic.
It's a beautiful song,
"The Anonymous Ones."
And you actually got to write
it, as well, or co-write it?
-Yeah, I did. Yeah.
I co-wrote it
with Benj Pasek and Justin Paul.
-The guys, the dudes.
-The dudes!
Those dudes rock.
-Fantastic.
I mean, "La La Land,"
"The Greatest Showman."
They pretty much know
what they're doing.
Yeah, they're pros.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I got to write with them,
and we did it mostly over Zoom.
-That's wild.
-Which was just kind of
deranged, honestly,
but really fun.
There were moments where --
There was a time difference.
I was in Copenhagen at the time
because I'm half Danish,
and I was getting my citizenship
so I can get out of here
if I need to.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you gotta plan ahead.
You never know.
-You gotta think ahead.
-Yeah, of course.
-And so I was doing that
at the time,
and so, often, our Zoom calls
would be at like 2:00
in the morning for me.
And so we'd all be, like,
bundled up
with our, like, blankets
and our tea
and just like hammering
in every single word and line
and deciding
what we wanted to say.
And, like, our coping mechanism
became breaking into
"Kiss By a Rose," by Seal.
-That -- That would
bring you back?
Yeah.
Whenever we were like,
"Oh, this is really tough,"
we would be like,
♪ Baby, I compare you to
a kiss from a rose ♪
Like, that was the way that we
would just kind of defuse...
[ Both singing gibberish ]
-♪ You ♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's a jam.
-What a song.
-Seal -- that's my jam.
-Such a good song.
-Well, for anyone who hasn't
seen the Broadway musical
"Dear Evan Hansen,"
which again,
this is Broadway week,
so please buy tickets to go see
these Broadway musicals
that are on Broadway and support
these actors and everyone,
the crew and everybody,
how do we set up
"Dear Evan Hansen,"
and how do we set up this movie?
-Sure. Well, I think
"Dear Evan Hansen"
hopefully addresses
a lot of kind of the ways
in which we all universally
struggle with mental illness.
And so, hopefully, it serves
as a place for people
to feel seen and understood
when it comes to dealing
with depression and anxiety.
And, you know,
all of us who are a part of it
have dealt with that,
are continuing to deal with that
in some way, shape, or form.
And the film is really
just about knowing
that you're not alone
in that experience,
that it's normal to struggle,
it's normal to feel weird
or deal with social anxiety.
And, yeah, I hope that it makes
people feel that way.
-Yeah. Well, it was --
You're fantastic in the movie,
and you're
a really good dinner date.
I loved sitting
next to you, bud.
-I had a really
good time with you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Amandla Stenberg
in "Dear Evan Hansen."
Take a look at this.
-♪ You ever
look at all the people ♪
♪ Who seem to know
exactly how to be ♪
♪♪
♪ You think they don't need
piles of prescriptions ♪
♪ To function naturally ♪
♪♪
♪ Well, look again,
and you might catch it ♪
♪ Just stay a minute more ♪
♪ There's this little moment
after the sunny smile ♪
♪ As their eyes fall
to the floor ♪
♪ The anonymous ones ♪
♪ Never let you see
the ache they carry ♪
♪♪
-Yeah.
That's how you do it.
Amandla Stenberg!
"Dear Evan Hansen"
is in theaters September 24th.